[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wir suchen heute das glück
mit einem kreativ duo das sein glück in
unterengadin gefunden hat mit der
philosophin ariadne von schirach
glücklich macht uns immer das wachstum
all diese dinge sind nicht konsumierbar
aber sie sind erfahrt ihr spuren das
glück besser wenn wir vom unglück wissen
sagt der französische literatur star
etwa dem glück ist viel schöner wenn es
ein sieg ist und außerdem das etwas
andere musikalische glücksversprechen
von steiner und matt liner
[Musik]
burundi und herzlich willkommen im neuen
jahr wir sind zum auftakt ins 2022 hier
nach kuba gereist und hier bin ich auf
dem weg zu einem kreativen
florina paddel und jeremy sabah sind aus
der großstadt hier ins bergdorf gezogen
um das glück zu suchen und zu finden
[Musik]
florina bordell und jeremy sabah sind
seit 2014 beruflich und privat ein paar
sie haben ihre beziehung zur kunst
gemacht ihre liebe untersucht ja sogar
im spital gescannt daraus entstand ein
buch und ausstellungen über ihre
zusammenarbeit und zusammengehörigkeit
für ihre arbeit zur wirkung von licht
und sonne erhalten sie 2009 10 den manor
kunstpreis im wallis drehen sie einen
stall um 180 grad die schattenseite
kommt so ans licht
adele sabah sind multimedial unterwegs
machen skulpturen mission installation
und video
[Musik]
ja wir haben ja in basel in wien in
berlin klappt jetzt zogen aufs land ist
bergdorf ist dass der klassische
romantische traum von der städte wo auf
einlagen die das glück suchen wir sind
froh auch wenn man einerseits gut
schaffte aber hängt austausch mit der
wahl seiner dänischen ort wo
man sein internationaler ort war und
kunst hotspot ist und andererseits
heimrekord und ich habe die hsf die
aktion und das wort gibt es nicht viel
was ihr braucht es da oben ist aber
lauten hier meldet braucht darüber wie
ich das verstanden ich frage möchte ich
wirklich gerne gesellschaftlich
engagieren als bis 60 wird gern
politisch
engagierte schmidt einfach
mental sie von der gemeinschaft sowohl
mit der stadt gesehen ja in basel ich
habe damit möchte das schon sehr viel
gibt was ich da stand schon sehr viel
für mini werte für diversität wird so
eine welt wenn ich sie mir vorstelle der
ope hingegen ist das nicht so und ich
hatte wirklich cool ich habe bis pietrek
und des wetters ich meine das wegenetz
mich ja das war das schellen ursli tor
von olli kahn das ist doch schon recht
konservative wartung für sich ja es sind
halt viele projektionen und zum teil
auch reaktion auf mitglied im kreis
thema sind und mir sind auch zum aber
genau zeigen dass das nicht nur das
schnellste tor fisch sondern dass es
hier manchmal geht das ganze land und
aber auch ein wenig vom tourismus
abhängig sind und die rhythmen der
kunstschau im wohnhaus kann man das
getan
[Musik]
hier ist zum beispiel mall und lucky
racket schon also immer meine das ist
immer es verändert sich alle sind über
das ganze haus und immer das ist alles
sehr flexibel ist und dass es mir
glauben dass installiert ist
jetzt wäre jetzt das kulturamt
esskultur wurde mit wasserdampf schafft
es war sowieso das was funktioniert
[Gelächter]
und man gestatte austausch mit anderen
kreativen naja ich glaube es gibt ganz
anders bei diebstahl was soviel klärt
die wir halt wo in der temporär oder
permanent da wohnen müssen wir haben
nicht einen sagen es glück ja und
außerdem holen die leute auch ins fuß
mit der präsident sich für danke und
dann krinner und die lucia und zwischen
1 bis 6 monate schaffen das ist einfach
auch sehr inspirierend inspirierende
frau holle eigentlich wollt dann genau
das ist das glück überhaupt sondern
flüchtige mann der ein erstrebenswerter
zustand und antworten
glück glück glück
lecker
[Musik]
märchenstück rica familienfest glück
dass sie mit freunden und gemeinschaft
dankbar ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem glück beschäftigt sich die
deutsche philosophin und autorin ariadne
von schirach
sie kennt sich bestens damit aus er
gründete in einer wöchentlichen kolumne
was uns glücklich macht
diese texte hat sie in ihrem aktuellen
buch zusammengefasst
glücklich machen uns naturerfahrungen
und glücklich macht uns inneres wachstum
all diese dinge sind nicht konsumierbar
aber sie sind erfahrbar und sie sind
eine belastbare antwort auf die frage
richten glück nach dem sinn von glück
erscheint uns dann eher als etwas das
uns zu fällt eine goldene zeit eine
wunderbare begegnung an der
liebesgeschichte usw
also doch alles eher zufall nur bedingt
sagt die autorin glück kann erarbeitet
werden die idee ist ein zufriedenes
leben zu führen und dadurch das glück
anzulocken und ein zufriedenes leben zu
führen bedeutet sich zu kennern sich
anzunehmen aber auch sich zu erziehen
weil wir selber sind oft unser
schlimmster feind und die suche nach dem
glück beginnt damit sie selbst ein
freund zu werden
sich selbst ein freund sein klingt gut
was gehört sonst noch zum glück
romantik zu bringen und zu recht
unbeschwert
und hat so einen zustand haben
eigentlich keine sorgen und gedanken
besonders ist für mich eigentlich glück
dass ich bleibe und transit version im
august
der bundesliga so dass wenn das mit
klingt das etwas glücksmomente wenn man
irgendwie dem vermeintlichen glück ist
stellt man fest wie vergänglich ist
das vergängliche glück das glück mit
anderen menschen das glück mit sich
selbst
ariadne von schirach meint mit ihren
glücks versuchen aber nicht
selbstoptimierung nicht dass ich gegen
aussen aufpimpen sondern nach innen
schauen und sich in lebenskunst üben
dabei denken wir oft das glück stehe uns
doch zu als standardausstattung
sozusagen für privilegierte erst welt
menschen leute wie ich zum beispiel sind
an einer sehr privilegierten position
ich habe die zeit ich habe die muße ich
habe den raum darüber nachzudenken wer
ich bin wenn ich sein möchte wenn ich
auf keinen fall sein möchte aber doch
immer wieder werde und so weiter und das
ist sozusagen ein privileg und teil
dieses privileg ist das auch immer daran
zu erinnern dass andere das nicht haben
und sich dafür einzusetzen dass zu
ändern
hat die suche nach dem glück
selbstverwirklichung aber heute noch
eine berechtigung
angesichts von klimaschock und corona
krise
ein glück da hat beginnt dass wir
darüber nachdenken wie wir uns selbst
und den anderen und dem leben gerecht
werden der liegt genau in dieser krise
die notwendigkeit zu überlegen was uns
eigentlich wirklich glücklich macht und
ich kann ihnen das ganz klar beantworten
am glücklichsten machen den menschen
menschliche beziehungen tiefe
menschliche beziehungen das kostet nicht
das kostet zeit das kostet liebe geld
das glück ist also oft nur den
sprichwörtlich einen schritt entfernt
liegt mit der normalität zu bringen das
glücksgefühl gemeinsam situationen mit
mehr entscheiden so
einfach nur so ja sagt komplett lagen
wie und mit wem wird daher im markt oder
soll denn jetzt wahrscheinlich schwierig
dass man glücklich mit
unternehmen
dankbar sei dank war glücklich glaubt
schon an zahlen
zuletzt noch die frage an die glücks
philosophin was sind ihre ganz eigenen
glücksmomente
wenn ich mich mit einem menschen
unterhalten und austauschen wenn das
kind morgens zum kuscheln kommt wenn ich
etwas sehr gutes zu essen habe wenn ich
ein frisches buch aufschlage dass ich
noch nicht kenne
wenn ich aus der sauna darlege nachdem
ich abgekühlt habe ich das erste mal
dass mehr sehen kann der langen fall
für das klicks
[Musik]
wenn ich da und video mit clowns
beschäftigen
das ist
mir jetzt zwei jahre geschafft und das
heißt auch dort und müssen ausgang von
der perma genese die pflanze also
fähigkeit vor pflanze produzieren die
pflanzen wo wir darauf finden dass ich
in seinem orden botanischer garten ich
hoffe ich stelle dies bis jetzt grade
wärmer und ausgehend von dem machen wir
den philosophischen reis durch
wärmefluss energie durch und bca
zwischen pflanze tier und man schon
jetzt schaffe dir ja als barzahler das
heißt er schaufelt augsburg ist das
glück aber das unglück ist das schwierig
aber ich
finde dass ich das große glück dass sich
apple kunde habe und ich rede so
spielerisch und unschön heiner schäffer
und das ist ja auch nicht immer ganz
einfach der autor schafft aber das hat
sich das sehr organisch entwickelt und
das funktioniert so gut dass in comic
strip expert geht doch immer
mal wieder aber was böses ist das
interessiert findet zum beispiel für ihn
war es
anders als man muss auch nicht immer
wir schaffen sehr vielschichtig und
dadurch jede das im jahr stattfinden wo
wollen gefallen und ich wünsche mir
einfach so intensiv wie möglich und wenn
wir da sehen wir noch geschafft und
jetzt natürlich nur um so intensiv wird
und aus einer kassette des auges
vermischt sich alles bis für mich ohne
und schaffe und schaffe und lebe und
denke und es ist wie alles eis corinna
du hast als erste frau mit romanischer
lyrik der schweizer literaturpreis grüne
was ist das für größer noch nicht 20 20
schon selber ist da und natürlich also
wenn man auf einer mal schreibt und den
analytik denn ich muss
wirklich so eine bestätigung dass
das ist einfach so weitermachen mit
auseinandersetzungen sprach und das ist
besonders wahnsinnig interessiert und
nimmt den ball auf meisterschaften
literatin richter macht schon was auch
gelang ja im moment leider metallic für
das mit der wirtschaft um den roman als
anstrengender ist christin größere
burgheim figur
das langzeitprojekt
als nächstes zu zwei jungen musikerinnen
steiner und matt liner sie kann sich
zurzeit schreibt das empfindet es als
großes glück und jedes aktuelle album
heißt wünschen glück
[Musik]
viel zu sagen und verantwortung zu
tragen
mama liebe so heißt das neue lied vor
nora steiner und model einer berliner
ein song der gerade erst am entstehen
ist ein lied voller emotionen
[Musik]
zigmal
nein
leben
ob proberaum oder konzertbühne wer die
beiden zusammen erlebt weiß wo sie das
glück finden
eigentlich was man alleine würde ich
[Gelächter]
wünsche mir glück nennen sie ihr
aktuelles zweites album beziehungen und
ihre eigene stellung in der gesellschaft
werden reflektiert den titel der platte
wollen sie ganz wörtlich verstanden
wissen
[Musik]
mit dem fuß und ich glaube
mit dem release vor dem 2
nach meinem glück rasch immer berufen
zu tragen
[Musik]
ich habe
auch wenn glück im album eine rolle
spielt ein bisschen wütend sind die
beiden auch vor allem dann wenn es um
veraltete rollenbilder der frau geht und
mit denen werden sie als weibliche
künstlerinnen noch viel zu oft
konfrontiert
[Musik]
us grund stand ein ich sage ich zu
diesen platz will eine alle sagen du
bist in einer privilegierten situation
wenn du hast jetzt den platz der am
festival danken wir mal wie sowieso sehr
ruhig man höre musik ist leider muss ich
mich bedanken
[Musik]
touren und konzerte spielen wenn der
funke beim publikum überspringt wie hier
2009 10 auf dem gurten das sind starke
glücksmomente für die wand von steiner
und man kleiner doch seit der pandemie
sind genau diese nicht mehr so
selbstverständlich
keine einfache zeit für die beiden
musikerinnen und doch das glück machen
sie nicht nur von der musik abhängig
[Musik]
und jetzt noch good news steiner und
marina gehen im kommenden april auf eine
kleine clubtour in der schweiz die für
die kita tour quasi ihre eigene glücks
mission
nein
[Musik]
ja ich habe
sogar ein grün das sind als
die anderen florin zu heiße
vergangenheit alle stadium das mit
brandauer lokale bevölkerung zum
thema druck vom immobilienmarkt wirklich
lecker
was mir in verschiedenen verschwunden
und auch für ein begegnungsort
dauerschleife oder mein süßes das
ist in der tat ein hauptschüler es ist
ein bevor die vereine der angebliche
techtelmechtel mit einem jahresgewinn
und es ist ein erfolg dieser segmente
gibt was ich weit weg von jeder und war
zwar gab es mittags problem hat mit erst
vornehmen ich hätte wahrscheinlich in
metallic sie dass man möglichst
gastfreundlich ist nun merken wir jetzt
langsam dass man das ganze potenzial und
die sie dafür verkauft haben jetzt sehen
wir beim unterengadin sein hotspot von
der grund was ist das problem war der
heimische mechanische qwertz das hat man
doch der vollprofi jaja das profitiert
schon komisch eines problems problem ist
einfach dass ist kein honig ermöglicht
für manche war das ganze jahr und ohne
probleme das 2006 initiative eigentlich
die andere sache als dass man dank
problem
nationen planen
glücklich so hoch dass wenn
ich es extrem schwierig sind zum
beispiel geschäftszahlen und der
faktisch auch das oft einfach immer
anspielen zudem verfassen
die ganze altbestand wird die höchste
deiner dort für die schnitt geschätzt
wird der zweiten initiative das sind
dafür sind potentielle feriengäste und
das passiert wird die letzte mehr als
baron ist extrem wirklich als liter türe
zum freitag mit dass sein verkaufen es
wird gar nicht wirklich hätte 12
das steht auch so war das gesetz im
spiel in zürich muss nachweisen die
gentrifizierung von der stadt ist das
überhaupt nicht haben ist das überhaupt
realistisch glaube durch seilschaft da
ist das august fanden aber auch mit dem
friedhof hat eine große hilfe die sind
so groß dass hier das auch mehrere
familien ausweis konnte war also ist
eigentlich wichtig dass man mit mancher
sensibilisiert und seite wenn man es mit
einem einzigen kanal für das zwei
familien und nordirland schaffen und
jeder einzelne kann sich fragen wie viel
geld brauche ich denn für missglückt
das maximum von glück haben wir uns
ziehen überhaupt auch im laufen
ich glaube es ist also für mich ist
wichtig dass ich einfach frei und
selbstbestimmt und
das ist mir wichtig ist und ich habe
das auch nachvollziehen das macht mich
glücklich weil ich durch eine chronische
am anderen tag in die rückrunde haben
das auch mit anderen mannschaftsteilen
[Musik]
ist passiert die witterung stelle neue
ideen zieht der französische literatur
star der stunde etwa louis und er hat
ein ganz konkretes
können wir die plätze tauschen ich fühle
mich in der mitte nicht sehr wohl
im mittelpunkt stehen muss er mag es
aber nicht louis ist eigentlich ein
scheuer mensch und bestsellerautor zwei
stunden vor dem auftritt im kaufleuten
zürich
allein sein debüt roman verkaufte sich
über 200.000 mal in frankreich nachdem
er über sich und seinen vater
geschrieben hat ist jetzt seine mutter
dran
die scheiben im buch über ihre mutter
von einem foto
ein kurzer moment des glücks
warum ist diese moment verschwunden
ich fand dieses bild auf dem meiner
mutter vielleicht 18 oder 20 jahre alt
war auf diesem foto war meine mutter
glücklich lächelte und ist voller
hoffnung
man kann es an ihrem gesicht ablesen
dieses buch ist eine art archäologie der
zerstörung dieses lächeln
ich versuche zu zeigen wie sehr gewalt
armut elend männliche gewalt mein vater
dieses glück zerstört haben
die mutter von zu vielen kindern sehen
sich nach einem anderen leben nach dem
glück dass sie sich einst als junge frau
erträumt hat die familie lebt im armen
norden von frankreich ist teil der
arbeiterklasse
die mutter hat ihn familiengefüge die
schlechteste position
[Musik]
mein vater die männer um sie herum
erwarteten von ihr dass sie sich auf
eine bestimmte weise verhält sie sollte
die kinder erziehen jeden tag das essen
zubereiten das haus putzen keine
lohnarbeit haben einfach zu hause
bleiben weil sie arm war und aus der
arbeiterklasse stammte war meine mutter
zweifach in der rolle als frau
festgezurrt denn wie kann man fliehen
wenn man einen gewalttätigen ehemann hat
wenn du kein geld keine diplom und keine
kontakte hast meine mutter sagte mir
immer ich wollte seit jahren flüchten
aber um wohin zu gehen
geflohen ist er selbst aus einem für
einen homosexuellen jungen mann
toxischen umfährt mit das ende von eddie
gelingt ihm der internationale
durchbruch als chefs stellen
2017 wird der roman verfilmt wird
ausgestoßen und gequält weil er sensibel
und feiner ist nicht dem konformen bild
eines mannes entspricht es sind abgründe
die sich da auftun was hast du dein
gesicht was sich geprügelt
meine mutter hat nichts mitbekommen und
keine ahnung was in der schule los war
die bildung das studium in der großstadt
ist seine rettung
ist es einfacher das glück zu finden
wenn wir auch das unglück im leben
kennen
ich erinnere mich als ich in paris am
kann um zu studieren und mit dem
schreiben begonnen habe da saß ich in
einem café und fühlte mich so
unglaublich glücklich weil ich dachte
ich sollte nicht sein mit meiner
herkunft sollte ich nicht hier in paris
sein ich sollte nicht studieren all das
was für die leute die in paris
aufgewachsen sind und aus privilegierten
kreisen kommen ganz selbstverständlich
ist in gewisser weise habe ich aber auch
für sie gelitten
weil ich dachte sie erkennen ihr glück
nicht sie sehen nicht wie schön es ist
einfach nur in einem café zu sitzen denn
schon ihre eltern und großeltern haben
das so gemacht für mich wiederum war
jedes kleinste detail in siek und
etwas ähnliches ist wahrscheinlich auch
im leben meiner mutter passiert
war vorbild für die eigene mutter sich
doch noch zu befreien
das gelingt ihr sie verlässt ihren mann
zieht in die stadt wie ihr sohn mit 29
gehört zu den führenden intellektuellen
frankreichs das schreiben ist ihm zum
anker fürs leben geworden teil seines
clubs
warum sind sie schriftsteller geworden
um zu kämpfen es ist wichtig mit natur
zu machen die die leute mit dem
konfrontiert was sie nicht sehen wollen
wir alle wissen dass wir in einer
rassistischen und homophoben welt leben
alle wissen dass in gewisser weise hat
uns die literatur nichts zu leeren aber
zu zeigen ja das ist das was ich tue
wenn ich schreibe ich versuche die leute
mit dem zu konfrontieren was sie schon
wissen aber nicht sehen wollen
ja wer zu noch hunger und ausflüchten
schlüssel und da wir verabschieden uns
hier von euch beiden herzlichen dank für
viele wahrscheinlich das nächste woche
geht es weiter mit der impfte botte eine
schöne woche
[Musik]
locker
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
fristlos